pas
encore
malgré une chaleur écrasante les ciel et
noir enchaînent les exercices sous
l'oeil avisé du coach et de son
assistant en enchères ne perdez pas de
temps
endurance vitesse précision maintenant
que la marche r1 n 3 est franchie
l'objectif est de faire la meilleure
saison possible
quand on est à tour comme je disais
qu'il faut absolument remonter bon je
parle à mon témoin doit remonter
pour monter il faut gagner beaucoup de
matchs donc automatiquement pour marquer
des buts il faut avoué l'attaquant mais
tout en gardant l équilibre c'est
l'équation la difficile équation du
football attaquer mais entend défendre
donc on va s'atteler à trouver la
meilleure formule possible parmi
l'effectif renouvelé de moitié des tout
jeunes locaux n'y a ni samoudi 22 ans
issu du centre de formation du tfc et
finaliste de la coupe gambardella en
2018 il affiche ses ambitions
ce duo le plus possible de faire des
statistiques dix nouvelles recrues pour
étoffer une équipe en attaque et en
défense qui pourront compter sur leur
capitaine gardien s'est soudain cadres
et les et nouveau faire en sorte que
ceux qui se trouvent dans les bonnes
conditions pour pouvoir
parfaire leur condition est
très réceptif aussi aux messages que le
coach va on va donner
côté supporters on ne lâche rien une
passion foot chevillée au corps depuis
tout petit pour certains depuis depuis
mon plus jeune âge c'est mon père qui
m'a emmené au stade donc ça fait une
bonne dizaine d'années puis 2006 2007
des années comme ça où j'allais à la
vallée du cher avec mon père et puis
voilà puis ça s'est transmis ensuite
donc voilà on espère évidemment la
montagne de sa part être facile parce
que quand même des gros des grosses
équipes des gros adversaire en face de
nous mais on va tout faire pour voir
aller au stade on va les pousser un
nouveau tfc qui aura aussi un nouveau
maillot avec les couleurs phares du club
le bleu pour les matches à domicile et
le noir pour ceux de l'extérieur
pour longtemps